congratulations on this new movie I mean
it's pretty good man I like it oh nice
you were [__] edgy nice nice I'm
impressed how you get rid of the accent
really yeah I mean seriously what do you
do on this I just I was just hanging out
in New York for ages um and you listen
to people if I just hang out with
someone for I'll start it's like a kind
it's probably an element of being really
shallow like I'll just start turning
into the other person and it's an
impression in other words yeah it's kind
of an impression if you and I try and
arrange my life around various different
people who I want to kind of be part of
the character I me that that sort of
just becomes that it's like a multi
impression do you stay immersed in the
character like do you go up to the craft
Services table and go uh hey give me a
hot dog you know or or something like
that you know what I mean yeah I mean
it's like sometimes and it's kind of but
I mean I mean the way this was written
it was WR you could feel everyone who
everyone's from Queens who wrote it and
they're like directing and everything
and it's kind of it's written very very
Queens dialect yeah um and it's just
it's nice for me like if I'm reading
something and it feels foreign it feels
alien it's kind of inspiring when you
see it when something's written in a in
a specific dialect very specific dialect
is it true for this movie good time that
you went like to some place in Yonkers
to an auto body shop and you tried out
your character on those people to see if
like you walked up and you know did the
character to see if they'd even know it
was you is that like a test to see how
much you got it down yeah and we worked
in a in a carh too like as uh me and and
Benny who's one of the directors one of
the two brothers who directors and that
that guy's one of the directors the guy
who plays your brother yeah oh no
kidding yeah he's great yeah the two
brothers directed it mhm what if one
doesn't know what the [__] he's talking
about and the other does or is this not
an issue well I mean it's interesting
especially in the scenes when when one
of them is acting with you as well I
mean it's kind of it's uh it's
definitely an unusual situation but it's
kind of nice I mean that kind of
mania that you kind of feel in the movie
that's so kind of you know it's kind of
good because that you know that that
Josh and Benny brothers are like uh
they're very close to each other and
they're also kind of confident and they
they will argue about you know that both
of them want to get their point across
and uh and so if you're trying to kind
of um be the conduit for two people at
the same time it does make you feel like
kind of crazy and amped up um and I was
I thought it was really helpful actually
to have two people oh really they debate
do you guys sit there and discuss the
character and the scene and all thing
yeah I mean they're very New York as
well so it's kind of like yeah yeah just
do it like
this okay go I heard you call these two
brothers and you said hey I like your
movies if you guys ever want me a movie
I'm I'm there for you right you said
that yeah yeah I remember meeting them
some Hotel in La ages ago and it was
literally there was there was no script
there was nothing really yeah and it was
off the strength of I just knew there
was something about them I knew there
was something good going on so they
wrote this movie with you and mine I
think so kind of yeah I think they had
the idea like a sort of vague idea and
then uh I definitely knew that they
weren't thinking oh like and before they
met me they definitely went thinking I
want to do a movie with Rob pson well
the movie is called good time I love
that in the bank it is the best and we
shot that with no real permission or
anything and like literally doing a bank
robbery and there's like cops
outside 100% get shot that was smart it
was
crazy